where do you see things now that worry
about a month I would actually
distinguish between what we actually see
in the markets and the story that Wall
Street is telling the story that Wall
Street is telling is all optimistic
we're gonna have all this boost economic
growth a lot of that seems to me to be
based upon wishful thinking if you look
at a chart of the stock market over the
past ten years you see this big dip with
the economic crisis and there's huge
huge rise and then there's a little
further wiggle at the top which is
what's happened since this election the
markets are not in fact building in huge
optimism about Trump I think they are
probably under weighting the chance of
catastrophe
greg's it was another recent world event
where a lot of people in the immediate
aftermath said oh this is going to be an
economic catastrophe that hasn't quite
happened yet but it sounds like maybe
what you're saying is be careful about
getting too comfortable well actually it
wrecks it was a huge shock to the
European project it's the consequences
five years ten years down the pike could
be really severe it did not put people
with zero experience in charge of
running the British government it's
people with long to experience it's
competent they talk to people who are
are reasonable but it's nothing at all
like what happened here there's this
global moment that populism is having
ayran hearing that it's certainly here
but but in Europe as well that rise of
populist leaders you wrote recently that
that term is is somewhat miss attributed
to Donald Trump in the sense that in his
first few weeks he has pretty much been
citing economically with big business
versus the individuals he populist we
can mean a bunch of things and normally
when you say populism you have in mind
someone who is is in fact going to soak
the rich and do all kinds of stuff for
the populist and is doesn't care about
the elite
[Music]